sup everybody welcome to LED live where
we expose darkness there's a light of
Christ we're gonna be talking about ESMA
rise that the media really affect you
know this presentation really is coming
out of all the questions that we get if
you read through any of our comments on
any of our LEDs you'll see people all
the time going you know what I'm a
Christian you're a Christian I can watch
whatever I want to watch and this
presentation hopefully will set this
answer straight are you truly affected
by what we watch find out on this
episode of LED live all right guys so I
titled this presentation mesmerised now
candy what is mesmerize me mesmerize
when you're just like infatuated
something like it's consuming all of
your attention and senses okay so like
you're kind of hypnotized right look at
what the dictionary definition of
mesmerised actually is it says to hold
the attention of someone to the
exclusion of all else so as to
transfixed the meaning literally you
can't see anything else
all right you ever been to the movies
yeah okay right have you ever turned
around when you're watching a movie and
just observe everybody in the theater
you ever done that dude is creepy
seriously
everybody's like this oh I totally
mesmerized and when you turn around and
you see that I mean you literally could
be like this and people are just zoned
out like right so I found a very
interesting that's why this was titled
mesmerized list let's unpack this a
little bit are we truly affected by what
we watch now I'm gonna give you a little
context because we're obviously
analyzing this stuff through the lens of
the Bible right Matthew 6 22 through 24
says the light of the body is the eye if
therefore the eye be single thy whole
body shall be full of light but if that
IV evil the whole body shall be full of
darkness if therefore the
light that is in thee be darkness how
great is that darkness now no man can
serve two masters he for he will either
hate the one or love the other or else
he will hold to the one and despise the
other you cannot serve God and Mammon at
the same time function here the last
part of that verse but when you see the
first part kind of put some context in
there yeah everything that we have in
our minds is taken in literally through
the eyes right I mean a big chunk of it
if you're blind obviously you get it
through the ears but a big chunk chunk
of our world view comes through our eyes
and so this Bible text is really telling
us listen if you're watching a lot of
dark things I mean just look at common
media right kind of dark right yeah is
that affecting you
the Bible says listen if you let dark
things into your eye
then the whole body will be full of
darkness right this comes from Psalms
101 verse 3 I will set no wicked thing
before my eyes I hate the work of them
that turn aside it shall not cleave unto
me now what does this verse mean to you
guys it's kind of hard to do nowadays
right because you're not even mainstream
just News you turn on the news or
whatever the case right down the street
there's wicked stuff all over the place
right but I love the end of this verse
notice what it says I hate the work of
them that turn aside now I mean you talk
about mainstream Hollywood movies we've
analyzed this for 10 years now there's
been a lot of content that little light
has put out that that is showing that
these guys are literally turning people
aside from a particular belief or your
understanding of God this is a piece of
advice from David proverbs 23:7 says as
a man thinks in his heart so is he
now when the Bible describes heart is
sometimes interchanges what we think in
our minds obviously right what you think
in your brain makes up who you are so do
you think that if you put things into
your brain it's going to affect who you
are right our bodies were like we're
like a computer and our brain is like
the software so a computer doesn't
really do any good unless you got
Windows or some kind of operating system
on there but if that operating system
has like little viruses and stuff it
starts acting up and I mean that's kind
of like with what's going on with us
we're putting all this stuff in our mind
thoughts become actions actions become
habits habits become our character and
our character becomes our destiny here
this very interesting right what you
begin in your brain if given the time to
its logical conclusion will ultimately
affect your destiny and that's why we're
even discussing some of these movies and
these topics and stuff I'm gonna give
you a little graph here this is the
American use of time what actually
people in the United States do with
their time this was taken from Time
magazine people generally sleep about
88.9 hours out of the day people
generally work 5.75 hours out of the day
people that play sports play video games
watch TV that's kind of what they're
lumping together for leisure time they
spend about 3.5 hours so that's three
and a half hours out of the day I want
you to notice the little pink line right
here people on an average spend 0.2
hours out of the day in religious
activities that's reading the Bible
that's going to church that's doing
things right that's so little compared
to the big chunk if you're watching TV
for 12 minutes 12 minutes mathematician
in the room 12 minutes you're spending
as opposed to three and a half hours of
doing something else that that should
tell you a little something we covered
this in selfie the documentary but I
thought it was appropriate to bring it
up here
CNN put an article out that was saying
teens nowadays are spending on average
nine hours a day playing with media nine
hours a day
candy what can you do at nine hours out
of the day every day so give me nine
hours a day out of four years what could
you become Wow yeah that puts it into
perspective right the more we play with
this stuff that we spend eight to nine
hours a day
and make this channel come alive and all
ahead of me I you could have your own
YouTube channel
it's basically what you're saying rather
than just watching YouTube you can have
your YouTube channel yes
so here's a little video clip that talks
about this how much time teens are
spending let's put that in perspective
that's watching TV watching videos
listening to music playing video games
reading scrolling around the internet so
it's all of that but it is 9 hours a day
and for teens it's about six-and-a-half
hour a six-and-a-half hours of their
time on screens so really what this
report shows Common Sense Media's
founder says it's like the digital
transformation of childhood and
adolescent adolescence is complete they
are now using screens and using media so
much more than really maybe when we were
kids I know for me every morning I
always watch TV when I'm doing my
homework that maybe I'm a little bored
of the topic I have to listen to music
to get motivated to do it so kids in my
generation have to do stuff like that I
don't speak for myself and I know that I
play video games with my friends and I
do that I think more than I actually get
some sleep sometimes I know that that I
was saying in my piece night yeah
Mountain Moms oh not now you know more
than teens typically sleep so if you
guys ever heard of Nielsen ratings have
you ever filled one out they send these
things to your house and Nielsen they
used to send out paperwork basically
randomly to survey who's watching what
what times do you watch what shows do
you like to watch and this is how they
were getting a census of basically who's
watching what TV shows and how much of
the population is actually engaged in
all this media so Nielsen actually put
this article out in 2018 so not not this
is only a year old it says the world has
never been more connected to media and
they're claiming that they have found
that American adults spend about 11
hours a day in front of media devices
now that's shocking to me 11 hours now
this isn't 11 hours like all the time
totally playing video games just
checking out this is playing with your
computer listening to music I mean all
this media impact how is this affecting
our society it's got to have some kind
of effect you guys can look this up on
the inner
there's a lot of graphs that show all of
this time and what people do with it so
I'm gonna play a little game with you
guys you guys won't play game okay so we
have a new intern and we're gonna play a
little social experiment with her this
is actually called the Solomon Asch
experience experiment where if you have
the group picking which line matches the
first line if everybody in the group
picks the same thing even though it's
wrong the PERT the likelihood of the 1
controlled substance or one controlled
person that does not know what's going
on that will pick the wrong answers just
because everyone else did so we're gonna
test this in the real world setting here
today hopefully this works she's a
graphic designer so even this actually
works so hopefully they're probably not
there's a little enough puzzles and
things but they don't think really well
if we can pull this off yeah so I'm
gonna play a little game with you guys
guys on play game okay okay and we're
actually gonna ask our newest intern to
step in here okay Michelle come on set
here yeah so this is a this is a little
game I want to play with you guys I want
you to match the line that is over here
on the left side of the screen I want
you to match her the right side of the
screen and give me your answer which one
do you think is actually the closest to
the thing go ahead keep whoo hey good
candy yeah hey Mikey
hey Michelle okay go ahead say yeah okay
candy yeah Adri okay okay go ahead with
this one Keith I'm gonna say C okay
candy okay Michelle
C alright how about this one Keith I'm
gonna say matches with a okay candy hey
Maggie okay okay
you picked a
you picked a yeah yeah so a is not the
right answer now that's pretty clear to
me what I think is very interesting to
me is this is actually called Solomon
ashes conformity experiment so what
happens was as I brought candy and Mikey
and everybody into the room before and I
showed them this and I had them pick all
of the right answers and the last one I
told Keith I said actually picked the
wrong answer and I want everybody to
follow suit with Keith what keep did and
you actually picked that because
everybody's the point I mean I was gonna
fuse between and me but it was so
similar or so but but after everybody in
the group decided that then you
second-guessed yourself right now I
found this mean very interesting because
Mikey actually brought this up you're a
graphic designer
mmm-hmm yeah so you actually probably
are used to staring at lines and spaces
and stuff I guess so the fact that you
conformed to the group is interesting to
me that's pretty powerful thank you for
stepping on you go back to shooting so I
want to show you this there is a thing
called social conformity that is very
very fascinating now check this out you
guys have heard of this elevator
experimented notices oh oh my goodness
this has been around for a long time
check this out this is absolutely
hilarious the gentleman in the elevator
now is a candid star these folks who are
entering the man with a white shirt the
lady with a trench coat and subsequently
one other member of our staff will face
the rear and you'll see how this man in
the Transpo
[Music]
to maintain his individuality
little by little
he looks at his watch but he's really
making an excuse for turning just a
little bit more to the wall now we try
it once again here's the candid subject
it comes the candid camera staff three
of them at least and this man has a
probably been in Group
[Music]
[Applause]
now here's a fella with his hat on in
the elevator first he makes a full turn
to the rear and Charlie closes the door
a moment later will open a door
everybody's changed positions
how I'll see if we can use
I will see if we can use group pressure
for some good now in a moment on charlie
signal everybody turns forward reverse
the procedure watch you gotta know after
all of that no no you know what's
fascinating he was the youngest yes the
youngest one yes there's a reason why I
chose Michelle when she came in here
because you guys are already kind of
like have your own voice and you're
already you know at this stage where
you're you know okay I can disagree with
this guy or whatever right but Michelle
coming into the group is new to our
group so she's gonna look at the group
mentality and she's gonna follow what
the group's doing and I found there's so
many things on the internet with this
time and time again this happens over
and over and over again and here's the
same here's the same example this is
pretty interesting everybody in the room
is aware of the joke in here but there's
one person that does not check this out
take a look at this crowded waiting room
these people may appear to be waiting
for the eye doctor but they're actually
waiting for the first test subject in
our hidden-camera experiment and here
she is right on time for her 12 o'clock
appointment how are you doing this woman
thinks she's here for a free eye exam
have you been here before
well it's my first time what she doesn't
know is that everyone else in this room
he's working for us I'll be with you in
just a couple minutes today we're
running an experiment on social
conformity and the test starts now
did you hear that these people sure did
[Music]
it doesn't take long for our test
subject to notice a pattern beep means
stand up but why and if you were in her
shoes what would you do the next time
the tone sounds while you might think
you make your decisions all on your own
when it comes to peer pressure
all too often your brain is just
following the crowd
it's all around you everyday an
invisible force you're probably not even
aware of it affects what you do how you
think and who you are it's called social
conformity or peer pressure and while it
might not sound like a good thing it's
actually not so bad the truth is your
brain craves synchronicity and takes
comfort in the ease and efficiency of
just going with a flow
and whether it's simply knowing what to
wear in the morning supporting your team
at the big game or even marching off to
war we're all programs to be part of the
group and that's because your brain
knows that there's power in numbers so
what I find is really interesting it
took only three beeps for that girl to
fall in line that's a short amount of
time right here's something else that
was kind of interesting they've done
experiments with people standing in a
line I've seen this you see this one
right yeah so it says the line starts
here right you have this guy who's
literally got into the line and there is
literally no rhyme or reason what this
line is for and there's nothing that
tells what it is so people are naturally
curious why is this guy waiting in a
line there's no explanation of why he
stood he's standing there now he's in on
the joke obviously
but he wanted to test to see if people
were curious enough if they would all of
a sudden come by and just stand in line
with him and sure enough they found out
over the course of time that's exactly
what people did then he decided to say I
wonder if people would actually follow
me and so he started taking them on a
little course right now keep in mind
these people have no idea why they're
waiting in line they're literally
following other people and he wants to
see how far and how ridiculous could he
actually get them to follow in this line
so he has this little obstacle course he
makes people do all these the funny
little things then he comes up to a line
that's in the ground and he says I
wonder if he creates an action would
everybody after him do that same action
meaning however he steps over the line
will that ripple down the line of how
people react to it and that's exactly
what they found out
people were literally doing exactly what
this guy was doing and it went all down
the line now you hopscotch I mean they
get all this like hilarious stuff and
these people have no idea why they are
actually in line I think this is
absolutely insane
but this is human nature we like to
follow what everyone else is doing right
what happens though if we decide to
follow something that is quoted quotes
dangerous what happens what happens if
everybody in the herd is literally
walking and jumping off the cliff
would that make you more susceptible to
that same type of activity this hotel
conference suite has been prepared for a
focus group discussion on internet
shopping but all is not as it seems
we've been busy
[Music]
the place is bricked with four hidden
cameras and six concealed microphones
and psychology professor Dominick Abrams
is watching from our control room which
we built in an adjoining suite now it's
just a question of sitting and waiting
right so this is a questionnaire all
about kind of shopping habits now
something helps us move out of your
chairs our first participant isn't
therein Mizuno a London student who
thinks she's arrived early what she
doesn't know is that behind this door
there's about to be a serious fire in
the hotel kitchen or at least the
illusion of one created by a smoke
machine and some sound effects what will
she do she's now noticed the smoke and
is concerned
at this point she decides to investigate
to find out what's going on she's
immediately taken responsibility for
figuring out what to do
Mary does the sensible thing and
evacuates quickly she even leaves her
bag and coat as I've never been in a
fire situation before I tried to
remember the kind of things that you're
supposed to do so I left my stuff and
and just went out but Mary was on her
own this time we've planted seven actors
who were all in on the experiment we've
said to them when you see the smoke do
nothing our second participant is Lauren
Heffernan also a student what will she
do in this situation
she'll be following the script the
script is partly written in her mind
it's a script which is borrowed from
things like sitting exams most
situations like this have some element
of expected or scripted behavior but
what will happen to her script when we
make a slightly unusual situation
very unusual nothing to start with so we
get her attention now how long before
she dashes out of the room okay question
how long until she actually leaves the
room maybe one at time yes
fifteen seconds Keith
I'm gonna well I'm just kept achill that
she's gonna leave the room
Mikey one and a half minutes so we've
got a full range here if she's gonna get
up quickly one and a half minutes and
she's not gonna leave it all watch this
time she's checking you clean to see
what the other people are thinking but
who can she appeal to the answer is
nobody she turns to the norm of the
group ignore the smoke in a real fire
the people in this group would be in
very serious danger by now
I was looking for some sort of reaction
from someone else even just the
slightest little thing that they'd
recognized that there was something you
know going on here for me to kind of
react on that and then do something
about it I kind of needed prodding
someone else to react why isn't anyone
else reacting she feels uncomfortable
she doesn't want to embarrass herself by
taking the lead taking action but
something is definitely wrong
Laurens stayed in the room for 20
minutes after spotting the smoke
concerned but immobile the fire brigade
say that if this fire had been real
even if flames hadn't burned through the
door she would have died of asphyxiation
in this time in the end we had to ask
her to leave I surprised that I didn't
do anything at all I was just literally
waiting I just thought that someone else
is surely going to say something soon
and because no one else did I just
didn't react at all we tried the
experiment 10 times and the same thing
happened over and over again if the
person was on their own they left
quickly if they were in a group of three
or more
they stayed rooted to the spot the
average length of time they stayed 13
minutes okay
13 minutes I don't know if you guys have
ever seen a fire been in a fire heard
about a fire that would kill you
right there literally because you are
conforming to the group and in fact they
have this exact thing that happened in
real life people died because of
behavior like this in 1979 a blaze at
Woolworth's in Manchester killed 10
people the fire occurred during the day
when the store was occupied by hundreds
of people most of those people managed
to get out quite safely the people that
died in fact we're actually using the
restaurant at the time
but why so many fatalities in the
restaurant investigators eventually
realized that people simply hadn't
evacuated they'd waited to pay their
bills that was their routine we go into
a restaurant we we sit down the waiter
comes over we choose a meal we eat the
meal we pay for the meal and then we
leave the building debts our script if
you'd like for eating a meal while still
everyone was following the same script
and no one wanted to be the only one to
stray one of the main reasons why people
died in the world with fire is because
they didn't want to be the first to
react they didn't want to stand out for
the crowd and went along with a crowd
behind you okay now isn't that crazy
think about this
spiritually guys think about this
spiritually the crowd mentality is going
this direction and nobody wants to stand
up for what's right but that's exactly
when Jesus is asking for us to do right
yeah right now there's gonna be a wide
gate going to destruction but you got to
go this way and the Bible calls us sheep
we got a sheep mentality like that no
wonder being a Christian builds
character it's not crazy that the people
are willing to die more than they are
willing to be embarrassed in front of
the group that's sobering and that
should really wake us up to like listen
if everybody's headed off in this
direction we ought to go hmm is that
really the right direction right because
we know that the Bible says that wide
and broad is the way that leads to
destruction right narrow is the path and
few will find it now check this out not
everybody in that experiment actually
stayed the entire time look at that will
it happen with this one guy that
actually got up only one person in our
experiment didn't go along with the
crowd behavior artist James McKechnie
it's a fire
is it fine if you just wait till she
comes back yeah just wait here anything
so just wait here I didn't say James
isn't going to sit in a dangerous room
just because everyone else does or is he
the power of the group proves
irresistible the reassurances of the
rest of the group that somebody else is
responsible seem to be sufficient to
pull him back into place instead of
leaving the room and calling for help he
sits back down again awaits
now everybody's looking at the smoke but
in some ways that gives the very people
more influence
after all if everybody can see the smoke
and no one's panicking well it would be
crazy for him to do it to James stays in
the room for another 10 minutes before
finally leaving in a real fire he
wouldn't have been a he'd have been
unconscious and close to suffocation
it's interesting that they try this
weather they say ten times there's this
one guy who reacts differently I've
always been told that when you have a
crisis situation you have about 10% of
people panic 10% of people rise to the
top and say this is what we need to do
and the other 80% of the middle looking
around and saying what are we supposed
to do alright where is the leader yeah
where's the leader because they just
kind of like you know that's why drills
are important that's why practice is
important you know like for example you
go to church or school or what have you
when you you do those evacuation drills
for a reason so that when that situation
happens everybody knows exactly what to
do you go down this hall you go down
these stairs and you go out to that spot
because otherwise all right if everybody
just sits there I mean I went to school
in Southern California for the first you
know few years of my life and we did
earthquake drills yeah I didn't get
under your desk I mean I remember even
being in an actual earthquake and you
had to get out you know so if you don't
if you don't practice and you don't make
your mind go into those situations and
think you're just gonna be standing
around looking like what what am I
supposed to do right isn't that
interesting and if you apply this
spiritually think about how many times
somebody stood up for right and the rest
of the group goes no no sit down
whatever
close your mouth stop talking about that
and how much that silence is the person
in the room and they'll literally go
back into the boiling pot like the
proverbial frog and literally die that's
crazy
with Jesus and
BRABUS you know a crowd one everybody
yeah and and the devil knows that we all
act like this so we showed this clip in
Magic Kingdom it talks a little bit
about our brains mirror neurons what's
going on but I want to bring this back
into the picture because it has a lot to
do with the influence of why we watch
and repeat what we see this is brand new
science this is just out of the lab we
may have some special circuitry in our
brains that helps us whenever we look at
each other well as it happens scientists
have an explanation for this strange
ability to connect it's new and it began
entirely by accident at a laboratory in
the lovely old city of Parma Italy where
a group of brain researchers was working
with monkeys and they were testing a
neuron that's a brain cell that always
fired made this sound whenever the
monkey would grab for a penis so the lab
had all these peanuts around and
whenever the monkey made its move the
neuron would fire scientists thought now
here's a neuron that is essential to
motion it's a motor neuron then one day
the monkey was just sitting around not
moving at all just sitting when a human
scientist came into the lab and when
that scientist grasped the peanut yeah
the monkey's cell fired now the monkey
had moved it was the human that it moved
suggesting that this neuron up here
couldn't tell the difference between
seeing something and doing something
seeing and doing were the same or more
intriguingly that for this neuron
watching somebody do something it's just
like doing it yourself to demonstrate he
put me into this very powerful fMRI
brain scanner that can peer into the
brain while it's working and he gave me
some goggles so he could show me
pictures when I was in there so you can
see here at the eyeball of Robert and
once she had a good view into my brain
nice looking brain
thank you Robert you're not supposed to
talk when we scan you all right sorry
then he said okay I'm gonna show you a
bunch of faces and for each face I want
you to imitate it so I did that
then he recorded my brain while I moved
my facial muscles we're gonna do right
away another one okay then he said okay
same faces but this time don't move a
muscle just look so I looked
when we check the results oh there's my
brain I've never seen my brain before
this is your liver iacoboni says that
the part of my brain that's working when
I make of things the same part gets busy
when I see the face so right there you
know what that tells me that tells me
that literally what we see people do in
our brains neurologically as is as if
it's happening inside of our brains now
think about that if you like murder
movies robbery movies
you're watching sorcery witchcraft
you're watching sexual immorality you're
watching all these kind of things to
your brain even though you're not the
one doing that activity you're watching
someone else do it
but neurologically it's as if you're
doing it yourself that's what this
experiment shows now listen to this
there is also a thing called the cult of
celebrity worship you guys ever heard of
this acting out just this week tabloid
favorite Lindsay Lohan have yet another
brush with the law but what impact of
this misbehaving mayhem having on your
easily influenced kids dr. Drew Pinsky
host of Celebrity Rehab is also the
co-author of the mirror effect of
celebrity narcissism is seducing America
dr. Kimura so obviously you're the
expert in treating celebrities but you
also study them so tell me what you
found and what the mirror will is two
things one is the study which is
something dr. mark young and I did he's
from the Marshall school does business
at USC and he and I realized that
celebrities really are not rendered
narcissistic by virtue of being
celebrity they come to their celebrity
status with a lot of pathology and our
research prove that then we wrote this
book that was published a couple of
years ago throughout this book off of
that research where we sort of coined
the term the mirror effect which is the
that the potential of our kids to really
mirror the misbehavior of celebrities
that we were bombarded with in the media
today so you say in the book that
celebrities you know they really the way
teens admit to copying tattoos and
things that shred is the world is
something called social learning which
is humans oh one thing humans do is
they learn from other people's behavior
and they model that behavior and in our
culture today two things have happens
almost really a perfect storm is in that
there's been sort of a turn towards
narcissism in all of us really it's
something that's sort of a trend that's
happening and the kinds of people that
we now elevate to really deity status
are severe an arsonist our research has
shown and their behavior reflects that
the problem is of the most Pro and the
most vulnerable amongst us tend to be
the ones that model that behavior at the
same time in which the celebrity and the
media industry have got together and
bombard us with these images so it's
really kind of a perfect storm right now
gimme yellow comes on I'll tell you what
when I wanted to be in Hollywood and
want to be an actor I literally wanted
to be like Brad Pitt I'll tell you a
funny story even of the whole Brad Pitt
thing there was a movie called Fight
Club don't know if you ever seen it
Fight Club old movie that came out in
the early 2000s and Brad Pitt wore a fur
coat in Fight Club I went out to a
thrift shop no joke bought a fur coat I
would wear this fur coat out in public I
think of it now and I'm just super
embarrassed of like oh my goodness
like I wore a girl's fur coat because I
saw it in a movie so I can identify with
this on on a personal first and I just
like Marilyn Manson and I've worked girl
things as well
I mean seriously I've seen pictures of
it might be like I this guy was a
Marilyn Manson's double yeah I think
music and you said Brad Pitt so that's
interesting but I think music is even
more influential in people's fashion and
tattoos and things like that
like I know people would probably like
get the same tattoo Lil Wayne hat or
something you know right right so I
think celebrities have an ax massive
influence over us in our culture it yeah
and it and I would say it really depends
on what culture you're in because I've
been told I have some friends have gone
to Korea I said it's the weirdest thing
you watch TV and it's not supermodels
and attractive people and all this that
are selling all the advertisement they
said it's older Korean men
interesting and the reason is because
they're the ones that are respected and
looked up to and all this so when they
get on television until you you need to
get this product everybody's like oh you
know the older Korean man said so so I
need to do that and so depending on what
culture you're and this can change but
but I guess my question is maybe you're
going here later
think about when you're a teenager the
amount of peer pressure there is to do
certain things right kids are at school
and maybe after school they invite you
somewhere and you know you find out you
know somebody had an older brother or
older sister or whatever somebody
brought the alcohol in you know somebody
got a kick so I'm gonna go to 12 back or
24 back or whatever and there you're
faced with now what do I do
because it's the same situation
everybody around you is now doing this
are you doing that are you taking that
first drink because well I don't want to
feel awkward I don't want to look weird
it gets a lot easier too when you're
older like our age to just say oh no I'm
good
I'll drink or whatever and people don't
even like pressure yeah that - to me
when you're a kid man to say that oh
goody two-shoes you can't take a drink
I mean kitten that's where they're gonna
that's where it starts you know you if
you make it to adulthood without
drinking then you might not ever drink
but if you start out you could get
hooked
peer pressure nowadays with social media
is literally like peer pressure on
steroids it's magnified and now that we
can share not only pictures of what
everybody's doing think about that you
had to go to that party and be involved
in that small group now all you got to
do is be friends groups with them and
see the picture and it's like all of a
sudden like I want to have a party at my
house with with alcohol you know what I
mean that's what the peer pressure does
so I want you to think about these kind
of influences when you even just look
through the titles of movies I just took
a screenshot of some of the movies that
came out a few years ago
this one's called act of violence is
that something that a Christian really
should you know be involved in the Bible
has a lot to say about that right
Matthew 5 21 and 22 says you have heard
of them said of the time of
thou shalt not kill whosoever shall kill
shall be in danger of the judgment but I
say unto you that whoever is angry with
his brother without a cause shall also
be in danger of that judgment what this
verse means is listen you don't you
don't have to actually go through with
the act of killing if you kill someone
you're in danger of the judgment of
killing but the Bible here out of
Jesus's own mouth says listen if you
just are simply angry with your brother
that same sin is attributed to you right
think about this sexual immorality is
rampant in Hollywood right here's a
screenshot of a film that came out a few
years ago it's called permission Kennedy
what does it say at the bottom of this
how can you be certain he is the one if
he is the only one tell me what you mean
by that
what what do you mean by that like how
can you be sure that this person is the
one if they're the only one you've been
with so might as well try new flavors I
mean how do you know you like vanilla if
if all of a sudden you've got like
strawberry have you ever tried to mix
them all you gotta mean like wow if you
just read the simple titles right but
here listen what Jesus says in Matthew
5:28 it says but I say unto you that
whosoever looketh after a woman to lust
after her hath committed adultery
already in her heart isn't this saying
exactly what the research was saying
exact you know about your brain you
don't have to participate in something
but once you see it once you visualize
it that's what's happening
excellent excellent viable relation
isn't that interesting science science
actually is beginning to prove those
things that were written thousands of
years ago and we know now because of all
the technology that we can test the
brain and see what's going on
we know exactly hey man Jesus had a lot
of like really like smart things to say
back then that we can test and prove
today the message in this verse is you
do not have to actually cheat on your
wife to be in danger of committing the
sin of adultery you literally have to
just look at a woman lustfully and
fantasize in your mind and you have
attributed that sin one thing we should
probably clarify with people
though is if you get to that point let's
say you've gone down this road you're
like okay you've lusted after the woman
in your mind in your heart it doesn't
mean go ahead and take the next step and
do it anyway because there is still a
distinction between carrying out the
physical act you know and thinking about
it it's it's like varying degrees you
know and you could take it so far and
then you could take it even farther and
it's best not to go there in the first
place but if you do go there in your
mind you don't want to go there in real
life tell your mind you just get into
God if you act out you got a Penta
everybody involved I think it caused all
kinds of that's right that's right so I
want to share with you another verse in
Romans 132 and I think this really gives
us a sense of how to navigate this idea
of really observing sin and what
correlation it has to us listen to what
the Bible says who knowing the judgment
of God they which commit such things are
worthy of death meaning listen if I go
and I rob a bank like these two guys
right I'm worthy of the judgment of
stealing and I could get in trouble just
like these guys could get in trouble in
in in God's eyes right but listen to how
the Bible even takes it one step further
and it says not only those that do this
same but have pleasure in them that do
them meaning if I'm just sitting back
and observing a bank robbery movie and
these guys are robbing this Bank and I'm
going yeah man this is so cool like
check out these ak-47s that these guys
are running in here and shooting up the
place like the movie heat or something
right I'm taking pleasure in someone
else doing something that it's worthy of
that sin so the Bible says something
that I think is an interesting principle
it says this is an amos
and I remember exactly I want to say
three versus three back of your own can
two walk together except they be agreed
in other words you and God need to be on
the same page
whatever God loves it's what you should
love whatever God hates is what you
should hate and by that I mean you know
when God says I hate something that
means I don't want that to exist because
it's destroying my people it's not that
God is being hateful in sense of I'm god
I'm gonna be mean and you know and carry
out violence because I mean it's it's in
other words I want to put that away from
the universe I don't want that to exist
I hate what it does to people yeah hates
the pain that it caused us a good way to
say it so when we think about our lives
and what's being carried out in our
lives we have to think do I love what
God loves you know am I on the same page
with God am i walking with God the Bible
says Enoch walked with God right because
him and God were on the same page they
wound up in the same place if we're not
on the same page with God and we just
say you know what I really don't care
what you love God I'm gonna love what I
love
you're putting your affections above
what God has in plan for your life and
how can you say that's the best idea
because the reality of the situation is
God had to die because someone ate a
piece of fruit ate a piece of fruit like
like to me that's like really serious
seriously a piece of fruit but what that
really effectively did was set us on a
course that was opposite than God we did
not walk with him after that start so
small something small and God had to
come down and die for that so when we're
watching things that are chuck full of
sin like literally Cinematic Universe
for Marvel right we went over this whole
series in length in our last led live on
this whole topic and you know we got a
lot of things from Christians going hey
I totally agree with
but I'm still gonna watch it so that's
interesting to me because if we really
truly are influenced by what we are
watching and they're sitting there
slamming god
non-stop painting a bad picture of God
painting him that he's evil and all he
wants to do is hurt and destroy you
right how can that not influence us
especially when the entire world is
wandering after this movie listen to
this this is the box office that that
they just had as of July 1st they have
made nearly three billion dollars on
this movie three billion dollars
worldwide the world is wandering after
this everyone's going to see it but what
if it's turning hearts away from God are
you gonna follow the group are you gonna
sit in that burning room with smoke all
around because you don't want to stand
up and literally say nope they're
fighting against my god right comment
from a mother who was kind of asking for
direction but she's seeing what we're
saying and she's like you know I'm
trying to teach this to my kids but man
it's like when they go to their friends
oh have you seen this movie like and
what are you supposed to say no it's bad
and you go back to the influencer back
to the peer pressure all the kids are
saying yeah we need to go see this and
and that's all the kid hears and listens
to he's more concerned about what his
friends think of him than what his
parent has to say or what he thinks God
thinks of him but but in a cosmic
perspective we're all in the same boat
right we care more about what's going on
in this earth and what everybody here
thinks of us than what God has to say um
how many of you guys have ever heard of
Netflix yeah actually what's Network you
ever heard I don't think there's a
person in our country that probably
hasn't heard of Netflix but have you
ever heard of the term binge watching
yep describe it
just English a whole season all in one
session that have you ever been watched
binge watch yeah you have guilty Keith
you know you have in YouTube I
I don't think I've been judged I mean
not in the sense of like a TV show like
a whole season or anything I I probably
have in a sense of like like Lord of the
Rings movies like before the next one
would come out or Star Wars movies
before the next one comes out you go
back and watch for Netflix yeah before
the Netflix age yeah so I found this
article very interesting from NPR they
were discussing what does binge watching
do to your your depression right our
world is suffering from depression and
listen listen to what this article says
Netflix and other streaming media
services have become the crack of
television making it possible to watch
entire seasons of shows like house of
cards or orange is the new black in one
go it seems like harmless fun but
headlines suggest that our binge
watching habits could be making us more
depressed and more miserable right it's
telling you literally if you binge watch
you are literally going to feel
depressed that's what that article
article is was basically getting us are
you gonna talk about why yes okay so New
York Post it wasn't just in PR that
noticed this New York Post this is what
Netflix binge watching is doing to your
mental health says New York Post right
there's an article after article that
pop up on the internet you guys can
search this out forever and there is
tons of articles that talk about the
more you binge watch there is this
correlation to the more you become
depressed now you guys have heard of the
Laodicean message what is it
lukewarm Christian walk right so you're
rich you're increased with goods in need
of nothing yep and God says you need to
do a few things to change that because
you're wretched you're poor you're
miserable you're blind you're naked
you need to buy of me gold you need to
buy of me you know white raiment and you
need to get from me some
to correct those conditions that's right
so I put the verse up here because I
want to point something out that I
believe actually Keith you pointed out
to me one time it says I know thy works
that are neither hot nor cold I wish
that that were hot or cold so that thou
were about because thou art lukewarm and
neither hot nor cold I will spew thee
out of my mouth and because I'll say as
I am rich and increased with Goods and
have need of nothing and thou knowest
not that thou art wretched miserable
poor blind and naked now question Mikey
what does the word wretched mean candy
bad like the lowest of the low kind of
just lowest of the low Keith I think it
means it's like a synonym for miserable
wretched actually means a very unhappy
or unfortunate State and listen some of
the adjectives to describe it is
depressed yeah now I find it very
interesting that the state of church
that is in the last day and age before
Christ comes again
he's the Laodicean Church right this
church that's I don't need anything I'm
fine I can watch whatever I want to
watch it does not affect me that's the
state that the church is literally in
yet they do not know that they are poor
blind miserable naked wretched depressed
yeah and we're dealing with depression
there they're not just unhappy they're
unhappy on top of being unhappy right
and you can see this correlation in our
world world once again science tying in
to what the Bible says science is
telling you you binge watch you watch
this stuff non-stop you if you watch the
entire season of Game of Thrones I
guarantee you you will feel miserable
afterwards and that is the state that
the church is found in but I'm trying to
find like the logic and the statement it
doesn't affect me because at the end of
the day if it didn't affect you you
wouldn't be paying to watch it you
wouldn't be enjoying it so there's like
this this block this blockage of people
not wanting to admit that they're being
affected by this whether it's good or
bad I don't think they're telling the
truth you are being affected
if I'm talking about not smoking weed or
somehow well get high like why would you
spend money to do that activity and
especially if it's illegal risk getting
thrown in jail for nothing I know I
think what it is at the end of the day
is people want to believe that what they
watch doesn't change their views you
know whatever those of use are doesn't
change their views on God it doesn't
change their views on anything that they
still believe whatever it is that they
believe yeah they think it's just
fantasy you know what is wrong how do
you come to those conclusions and know
what it is that you believe if you
haven't been influenced by something
previously see that says that's what I
was saying that is when you try to lead
to that conclusion it's like you can't
because there's this blockage of they're
not willing to admit that they're being
affected because if you can admit yes
I'm being affected okay why or how and
then we can have that discussion oh
maybe it's because I like the the
violence happening and you can see that
because when you're watching it your
heart starts racing or maybe you're
excited or over the case and then you
can line up okay I like this violence
but that's in contradiction with what
the Bible says maybe I am being
influenced or turned away from how I
should be living or what I should be
indulging in so I mean there's a process
and just like we're stuck here yep yeah
be people really do enjoy violence like
the video game has to be full of blood
and you're a software like it's not fun
unless it's super violent for some
people yeah those are the videos being
shared around or getting the most views
but they they also want to believe and I
think for most people this is probably
true if I watch that I'm not gonna do
that if you're in a video game and
you're blowing people to bits it's true
most people are not gonna go out and go
on a shooting spree but the people who
do that you know they fit a certain
profile where it's it's like they've
gotten to a certain point and they're
cracked after that
No there's all kinds of variables to fit
you know in that psychological profile
but the thing that's interesting is we
know from psychology people do things
they wouldn't normally do under unusual
circumstances right so all you have to
do is change the circumstances and now
people's behaviors start changing just
like the people we watched right in a
normal situation you get up and you
leave you change the environment you
change the circumstances now people's
behavior changes there was experiments
years ago they would have people like
torturing other people or at least
that's what they thought you know like
turning dials up you know and you know
things like this and where they know
somebody's going through much more pain
and they just do it anyway almost like
sadistically
and it's like well why would you why
would you do that you know they find
themselves under these adverse strange
circumstances and they they do things
they wouldn't normally take Jerusalem
years ago you know when Jerusalem was in
captivity people are stuck you know in
the city was being seized they're stuck
they can't go anywhere can't do anything
people ate their own children in nobody
right in their right mind under normal
circumstances does that right I think
there's incredible evil inside of all of
us human beings I mean that's proven
with the Holocaust that's proven with
throughout the history of time we are
capable of sheer evil and in people that
you wouldn't normally expect it right so
I came across this article with little
Wayne and Nicki Minaj and the state of
Florida says be et they were in the
state of Florida they were honored as
teachers of the year teachers of the
year so here's what's interesting to me
about this the article goes on to say
that they were a bit maimed best male
and best female teacher after judging
them on several categories deeming them
more influential than teachers who
actually commit themselves to children's
education you better bet these guys are
teachers what are they teaching your
children that's the question they're
teaching on a grand scale
through the meat music and through the
media but and that's why they were
literally honored as that I used to get
Time magazine at my house and I came
across this article with Taylor Swift
one time so I'm always naturally curious
about you know what does this celebrity
have to say and in the article Swift was
commenting on the fans that all follow
her music and this is what she has to
say this is Swift speaking Swift is
happy to minister to them I find that a
very interesting word choice wouldn't
you say they are discovering the music
of it how it tells them how they're
going to live their lives and how they
should feel and how it's acceptable to
feel Swift says I think that's kind of
exciting you know what I find
interesting about this is that literally
the only people that don't think that
the media is affecting them is the
people watching it that's right no look
at the next sentence to her fans she
recently started speaking out on to
connected matters of importance to her
the music business and feminism
why is she speaking on those matters to
her fans because she knows everything
that comes out of her mouth her fans are
gonna take notice they're gonna take
listen she has influence and it's gonna
change people's minds that's right so
it's interesting to me when you once
again and I know we keep hammering this
point when I hear people go whatever I'm
not affected by what I watch you go talk
to any celebrity and they will tell you
hands down time again they are fully
aware of how much they're able to affect
you and everyone else and they make
millions of dollars doing it I've seen
that clip I think it's Garth Brooks says
he could tell the crowd to put their
hands on the burning hot lights and they
would all do it seriously seriously
Time magazine did a study on the
celebrity worship is it good for your
health this is what it says in the
article new Sun and new scientific
research has found that celebrity
crushes are not only common but maybe
even healthy a spread a study published
September 10 suggests that the act of
celebrity worship made boon people's
self-esteem now candy do you really
think it'll boon and raise your
self-esteem following celebrity why
because it's unrealistic like it's very
hard to relate to first of all so I'm
killing myself trying to be like this
person they're just gonna leave
to my depression okay so now keep in
mind this is a real scientific study and
look at why they found what the reason
why people feel like they can have a
better self-esteem because people form
bonds in their minds with their favorite
celebrities they are able to assimilate
the celebrity's characteristics in
themselves and feel better about
themselves when they think of that
celebrity I thought I did at the time
but now looking back no I look like a
fool my question is can't you just
exploit that same principle to Christ
you certainly can in fact if you focus
on a certain celebrity all the time
right and who do you want to be like
like me I wanted to be like Brad Pitt I
wanted to walk talk wear the clothes
that Brad Pitt word what if I was
literally reading the Bible focusing on
the character of Jesus Who am I gonna
want to be like right if that's who you
are literally focused on and learning
about and and and trying to understand
who God is you're gonna want to be like
him if all you do is watch movies and
you these favorite superheroes or your
favorite characters and you know more
about that superhero or that comic book
character then you do the characters in
the Bible that's gonna tell you
something about where your life is gonna
end up it was actually a comment someone
said something along the lines of I
don't understand what you guys are
saying but I think it's a little bit
extreme because that it can be wrong for
someone who is spending all their time
doing it but what about someone who
actually goes to church every week and
is very involved yeah and not amazing in
moderation is very involved in
everything church and has they say they
have a deep connection with Christ and
they only watch this you know from time
to time for entertainment how can you
apply all of that and and that they're
being influenced actually I can answer
that in a simple way of putting it in
the context of my wife okay if you talk
about my wife we're gonna have some
problems right I'm not gonna have to be
very happy to have somebody in my life
sitting there dogging my wife and
telling her that she's you know no good
and this and that and she's this evil
person no I'm probably not gonna hang
out with this guy if he does that
so why are you gonna hang out with a
movie that's slamming your god I'm just
saying
okay what's the point of that yeah
people like to throw out terms I'm just
gonna use a correlation before I make my
point they'd like to throw out terms in
an interesting way for example the term
theory gets thrown out oh I was just a
theory like yeah it's just some made-up
thing in science a theory is right
behind a law which means they're just
waiting for you know one or two more
pieces of evidence and this thing is
done solid decided it's like gravity but
we toss it around in culture like oh you
know it's just something somebody made
of like it's no big deal
when people say you know well I'm just
doing it in you know moderation in all
things they're not understanding what
the Bible is talking about when it says
moderation it doesn't mean you know you
can take a little bit of something
that's bad and just you know just do
that a little bit what it means is
complete abstinence from things that are
bad and the things that are good
don't overdo them it doesn't mean you
know - it's like if you're gonna like
you have a religious show that you want
to watch obviously you're not watching
Church of Satan channel because you're
abstaining from things that are bad and
you might watch your religious show but
you don't do it for 14 hours a day all
right
you do it for you know an hour half an
hour whatever is reasonable right
because it's something that is good
uplifting it will feed you and you have
to apply that to you you know the rest
of your life
so abstaining from the bad and doing the
good within reason
yes all right so there's a lot of
articles on the internet that talk about
celebrity worship here's another article
that CBS put out and the the study that
was done here the doctor that did the
study fish-off he came to the conclusion
that the very need for us to find an
idol and follow him is actually
programmed into our DNA that is 100%
true in fact God programmed us to
worship but it's to worship Him and him
only right so I find it very interesting
and I'm gonna keep throwing Marvel under
the bus here because
all of those superheroes are gods
they're Greek and Roman mythology
repackage put spandex on them and hand
into our generation and the Bible is
very clear in Exodus 20 verse 2 3 have
no other gods before me right first
commandment alone that should do to her
any Christian from wanting to watch
those wouldn't you agree that verse and
another verse
no man can have two masters makes a very
important distinction that people don't
make in their mind you're not the master
that's right you are serving something
that's right and especially if if dr.
strange is the master of black magic
dark sorcery come on now Christians so I
want to talk a little bit about the act
of celebrity worship there was a movie
that came out called anchorman where the
hair was a really funny commercial that
they started releasing dodge commercials
that really highlighted the lead
character that was in anchorman and they
told you zero about the function of the
car they actually told you ridiculous
information about the car listen to this
you know a lot of people will tell you
about the dodge Durangos available Hemi
v8 engine and 360 horsepower but I'm the
only one with the guts to tell you about
the glovebox point 1 cubic feet of
storage 12-volt light bulb all in
beautiful injection molded thermoplastic
olefin comfortably fits to turkey
sandwiches six ball-peen hammers 70
packs of gums 20 rulers this thing goes
on four inches starting to get the
picture oh yeah this glove box I've been
talking about it comes standard so I
want you to show this after showing this
commercial ridiculous didn't say
anything about the actual function of
the car right look at this durango sales
went up nearly 40% no effect no effect I
mean just because they put that
celebrity in that commercial right so
Brad Pitt came out and did a Chanel
commercial okay and he was paid seven
million dollars for this commercial
I'm gonna play this commercial for you
and you tell me that if you like this or
not it's not a journey every journey
ends but we go on the world turns when
we turn with him plans disappear dreams
take over but wherever I go there you
are
look my fate my fortune there's no
number five inevitable first of all I
don't even know what he said I speak
English and I don't think he was and
second of all like my my seven year old
child could shoot a better commercial
than that but really I could have saved
you six hundred thousand and five
hundred dollars you could have paid me
half a fraction of that and I could have
shot you a better commercial but why
would they want Brad Pitt over me
because he has influence so if Brad put
wet wears Chanel number five mm-hmm are
other people gonna wear Catherine
zeta-jones was paid twenty million
dollars to put a phone in her hand
that's an incredible amount of money
twenty million dollars simply to have
that brand associated with that woman
that'll pay her phone bills the rest of
her life
Tiger Woods was paid 100 million dollars
to simply wear a Nike swoosh and and I
think like as much as possible he worked
everything Nike like how did pants shoes
you're not Al everything you're not
allowed to wear anything else yeah in
fact he cannot own a pair of Adidas
underwear can't do it literally he's
under contract to be a part of Nike
everything he has has to be that they
would not pay somebody an incredible
amount of money like that if it did not
influence and affect people right what
other human being would they say we're
gonna clothing for the rest of your life
and when I give you
you know it right now him to demonstrate
influence on the other end Tiger Woods
got himself into a bit of trouble right
yep and he was this squeaky clean you
know everybody looked up to him
sportsmen and then the scandal came out
and the cry of the people the upsetness
of the American people and people
started pulling their funding right we
dropping him like everywhere in the Nike
swoosh now why because people will
associate his influential life and go
out and do those kind of things or start
by and we don't want that right so what
celebrity do you think has had the
highest product endorsement Michael
Jordan I'm surprised I'm sure over time
Michael Jordan I think Michael Jordan
could be a more wealthy over the course
of time but in one given union paid one
given year one given what is the most
highest paid celebrity endorsement of a
product now this doesn't mean that the
celebrities paid that much but this just
means the product decided to pay him
this much - for if you need a hint of
you need a hand I'll give you the the
sport okay
it's sucker oh really it is no no David
Beckham really David Beckham is why I
can't believe it's David Beckham if you
live under a rock David Beckham has paid
160 million dollars for a contract
he's yeah for to wear adidas that's an
incredible amount of money from a
celebrity endorsement that product
placement most awesome plug we also have
these shirts available to you oh my
goodness here's what the Bible has to
say I want to wrap this all up for you
guys
Romans 12:2 says and do not be conformed
to this world but be transformed by the
renewing of your mind that you may prove
that what is that good and acceptable
and perfect will of God
you see God is promising that he wants
us to have a renewed mind he does not
want us to be influenced by the world he
wants us to be literally changed our
thoughts and thinking so that it is in
line with the will of God if you think
about it you know this whole situation
that we're in now earth the way it is
all started because of a choice of
influence you know God gave us he wants
us to have our own mind he wants us to
have the ability to choose but then the
grand influencer came in he said no we
won't eat it ah you know yes no I mean
can you even really trust that guy and
all these insinuations and because of
influence we are in this sinful world
today look at Adam sir coming to the
social pressures of his day only one of
the human one other human oh she did it
I know it's wrong but I'm gonna do it
you know Hollywood takes a page out of
that book well he's an attractive woman
it works first time see the devil knows
exactly how our minds work and that's
why we need a new mind we need a new way
of looking at things in fact the Bible
tells us in second Corinthians 10 verse
5 casting down imaginations every high
thing that exalteth itself against the
knowledge of God and bringing into
captivity every thought to the obedience
of Christ this is where God wants to
bring our minds every thought every
thought into the captivity of Christ and
when we do that when we let the Holy
Spirit into our lives when we let him
totally transform our minds we will then
be in line with the will of God
we hope you guys like this leb live we
want to hear your comments on this
especially if you are on the fence of
does media really affect us yes or no
we created this presentation to give you
a little background of influence we are
influenced by everything that we see
taste touch here and and especially what
we look at in a dark room staring at a
blinking light source and so check out
some of our other LEDs and if you want
to support this ministry check out our
patreon page we want to keep putting
videos out like this and we need your
help partner with us we've got a lot of
things to talk about we need more
editors we need more videos we're
shooting this whole thing with
absolutely no cameramen except for our
intern out here so we want help and you
guys can do that for us and we just
thank you for watching our stuff god
bless keep us in your prayers and we'll
see you on the next time around put your
comments below peace out
[Music]